اعلن وزير الدفاع البولنديه انشاء فرقه
عمل عسكريه بالقرب من الحدود مع بيلاروسيا
بهدف تدريب الجيش البولندي في مقاطعه
بودلاسكي جاءت هذه الخطوه خلال زياره
الوزير للمنطقه الحدوديه مع بيلاروسيا
وغداث اعلانه ارسال تعزيزات عسكريه الى
المنطقه على خلفيه ما تصفها الحكومه
البولنديه بالاستفزازات البيلاروسيه وما
تشكله عناصر من خطر على بولندا
ينضم الينا من الحدود البولنديه
البيلاروسيه مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
بوزيان نور الدين كيف تبدو هذه الاجواء
خاصه في ظل هذه التصريحات التي تصدر من
هنا وهناك حول نشر عشره الاف جندي بولندي
على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا
من الواضح جمال بان وزير الدفاع جاء لهذه
المنطقه خلفي على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا
لتوجيه رساله واضحه للطرف الاخر اي حكومه
بيلاروسيا عندما قال بان الحدود البولنديه
محدده واتهم نظام كما قال هكذا وصف نظام
بيلاروسيا بانه يتعاون مع الكريم وبتشجيع
من الكرملين من اجل زعزعه الاستقرار في
بولندا من الواضح انه قال باننا قررنا
انشاء هذه القوه او هذا قررنا تعزيز
تواجدنا العسكري في هذه المنطقه لاننا على
يقين بان هناك خطر على حدودنا وقال بان
هذه الاجراءات العسكريه هي فقط من اجل درع
العدو دون ان يسميه وتحدث عن اجراء
احتياطي كما قال من اجل ترى اي مخاطر من
اللافت ايضا بانه لم يقل اي شيء بالنسبه
للرساله التي وجهها الرئيس بيلاروسيا امس
عندما قال بانه امر الحكومه البيولروسيه
من اجل فتح اتصال مع الحكومه البولنديه لم
يرد على ذلك ولكنه اتهم بيلاروسيا بانها
تعمل على تصعيد الموقف في المقابل وزير
الخارجيه البولنديه تحدث مساء امس
للتلفزيون الرسمي وقال اذا اراد النظام في
بيلاروسيا تهدئه الموقف عليه اولا ان
يستجيب لعده شروط من بين هذه الشروط وقف
الحمله العدائيه وحمله الكراهيه ضد بولندا
واطلاق سراح بعض السجناء من اصول بولنديه
بالاضافه الى انه قال بان وردت عليه كما
تعلم قالت بان ما تريده الان الحكومه
البولنديه وتوسعيد الموقف من اجل اظهار
انها تسلحت جيدا خاصه مع اقتراب موعد
الانتخابات على حد تعبيره نور الدين ابو
زيان مراسل جزيره متحدثا الينا من الحدود
البولنديه بيلاروسيه شكرا جزيلا لك